[Musik]
der krieg ist in diesen stunden noch
näher an uns heran gekommen um ganz
genau zu sein er ist noch rund 20
kilometer nur von der nato grenze von
der polnischen grenze entfernt mit
diesem beunruhigenden nachrichten
beginnen wir diesen kriegstag hierbei
bild live und mit diesen beunruhigenden
bildern die stammen eben aus der nähe
von lemberg also ganz im westen der
ukraine dort gab es eine explosion
mehrere explosionen auf einer
militärbasis dort unsere reporter sind
sofort dorthin geeilt und haben uns
diese bilder mitgebracht von dort unser
bild reporter philippi adhoc berichtet
von mehreren toten und verletzten die
agenturen schreiben in diesen minuten
gerade neun tote soll es dort gegeben
haben philipp peter fast uns einmal
bitte zusammen vor ort an dieser
militärbasis nahe lemberg ganz dicht an
der nato grenze was genau ist dort vor
wenigen stunden passiert ich befinde
mich circa 50 kilometer entfernt von
lemberg und nur 20 kilometer entfernt
von der polnischen grenze also vor einer
nato grenze und hier sind vor wenigen
stunden acht russische raketen
eingeschlagen das ukrainische militär
hat mir bestätigt dass es tote und
verwundete gab auf dem weg gehen haben
wir sehr viele krankenwagen gesehen die
sehr schnell in richtung lemberg
gefahren sind um die verwundeten in ein
krankenhaus zu bringen das brisante ist
eben die nähe zur polnischen grenze so
weit im westen hat noch niemand hatten
haben die russen noch nicht zugeschlagen
das heißt bislang waren sie luftangriff
für die raketenangriffe fokussiert auf
den osten des landes auf kiew und hier
in der nähe gab es eigentlich nichts 100
200 kilometer von hier wurden einzelne
militärflughäfen angegriffen aber nur 20
kilometer vor einer nato grenze hat
putin noch nicht zugeschlagen und in
dieser nacht ist es eben dazu gekommen
worauf also diese beunruhigende
nachricht heute früh der krieg direkt
nach der nato grenze 20 kilometer von
dort entfernt raketeneinschläge und wie
wir gerade hören neun tote
57 verletzte dort auf dieser
militärbasis auf der auch ausländische
ausbilder im einsatz gewesen sein sollen
nur gleichzeitig gehen diese bilder um
die welt und die stammen aus dem osten
der ukraine aus der nähe von haag if
dort eine russische jet offenbar
getroffen von der flugabwehr der ukraine
stürzt mit einem feuerball zu boden und
wenig später dann auch am himmel zu
sehen die besatzung dieses jets die sich
offenbar gerettet hat letzter sekunde
und dann über ukrainischem gebiet
ebenfalls zu boden fällt von den
russischen truppen dort von der
russischen armee und wir sehen bilder
von satelliten die vom privaten
sicherheitsdienst max zur verfügung
gestellt wurden vorher nachher die
spuren des krieges in mario pohl dieser
hafenstadt die ursprünglich mal mehr als
400.000 einwohner hatte vorher
diese aufnahmen und nachher nach den
russischen angriffen das ist was sie
heute wissen müssen über diesen
kriegstag in der ukraine
der luftangriff auf eine militärbasis
nahe lemberg im westen der ukraine ganz
dicht an der nato grenze neun tote 57
verletzte allein dort die russischen
panzer die kiew quasi eingekesselt haben
und immer näher auf vier vorrücken und
dann gibt es weiterhin verwirrung um das
atomkraftwerk satoris ja das ist im
süden der ukraine wer hat da jetzt die
kontrolle wer hat da das sagen wie
sicher ist dieses atomkraftwerk das ist
die große frage an diesem sonntagmorgen
mittlerweile sind viele viele tausend
menschen evakuiert worden
das ist was sie heute wissen müssen und
wir schauen auf das was der ukrainische
präsident in den letzten minuten gesagt
hat herzlich vor allen dingen angesichts
der vielen flüchtlinge innerhalb des
landes in der auch der angesichts der
vielen menschen die weiterhin raus
wollen aus den städten zur humanitären
lage in seinem land geäußert
und wir gehen direkt zu unserem bild
reporter paul ronzheimer du hast den
präsidenten gesehen der sich mit diesen
worten eben an seine ukraine gerichtet
hat sagt uns einmal welche rolle spielen
im moment evakuierung raus über diese
korridore die ja auch immer wieder
beschossen werden immer wieder getroffen
werden
heißt es wahnsinnig kompliziert
wahnsinnig gefährlich für die menschen
aus den beschossenen orten rauszukommen
ich hatte gestern die möglichkeit am
bahnhof mit der mutter einer familie zu
sprechen die befreundete es mit einem
ukrainischen kontakt von mir und sie hat
darüber berichtet dass sie auf dem weg
von butscher das ist dieser vor ort von
kia überredet ihn immer wieder
beschossen wurde dass sie sich versteckt
hat auf dem weg nur zu fuß durch diese
kälte und am ende ist sie in kiew
angekommen hat am ganzen leib gezittert
und sich wirklich gewundert dass sie
noch am leben ist angesichts dieses
dramatischen flucht weg ist und das ist
genau das problem und die große sorge
die viele in der ukraine haben das eben
die flugkorridore über die immer wieder
gesprochen wird nicht funktionieren
beziehungsweise russland ganz bewusst
die russische armee diese flugkorridore
korridore bombardiert und willi lenz
gemeldet sich immer wieder in kürzeren
abständen hier zu wort und weist auf
diese dramatische humanitäre situation
hin also von humanitären korridoren kann
man definitiv nicht sprechen das ist
natürlich andere alles andere als
humanitär die menschen dort ja in
tausenden die ihre heimat
zu erledigen und sie dann auch noch zu
beschießen in diesem korridor wer sind
die menschen paul die jetzt die städte
verlassen es sind so viele millionen
schon auf der flucht also wer
entscheidet sich jetzt raus zu gehen
das sind vor allem menschen die tagelang
eingesperrt waren die sich nicht vor die
tür getraut haben die im keller
ausgeharrt haben weil sie wussten dass
der beschuss so stark ist dass sie da
nicht raus können das sind nicht leute
die bewusst entschieden haben dass sie
bleiben wollen sondern ihr ort wurde
beschossen sie kamen nicht raus über
tage und da sind familie da sind kinder
da sind frauen all die menschen die
jetzt raus rollen richtung westen erst
mal richtung kiew aber sie haben
natürlich auch teilweise die nachrichten
mitbekommen was mit zivilisten passiert
ist unter anderem dort auf der brücke
wir haben diese bilder gesehen von einer
new york times fotograf in die dort man
muss sagen am tatort war an dem ort wo
die russischen raketen diese familie
getroffen haben und davor haben
natürlich viele zivilisten angst dass
sie das gleiche schicksal erleidet
flucht korridore die beschossen werden
und jetzt sehen wir gerade aus lemberg
diese ersten bilder die philippi ad hoc
dort mitgebracht hat von dieser
beschossenen militärbasis also der krieg
jetzt auch ganz im westen der ukraine
angekommen ganz dicht vor der haustür
der nato es gibt keine sicheren orte
mehr in der ukraine
das ist richtig es gibt keine sicheren
orte mehr und wladimir putin will
natürlich genau das erreicht er will
panik schön er will das sehen was er
schon in vielen teilen des landes gesät
hat nämlich die angst davor in diesem
land zu bleiben und dazu und das hat die
russische armee gestern angekündigt
insbesondere den westlichen staaten zu
zeigen dass sie auch dort attackieren
werden dass sie dort bombardieren werden
wo ja westliche waffen vor allem
ankommen über polen richtung ukraine
länder ist ja ein ganz wichtiger ort
dafür um weitere raketenabwehrsysteme
weitere waffen hier richtung hier zu
schaffen danke in die kriegs hauptstadt
kiew für an unserem bild reporter poller
und summer danke bis gleich